S
TRUE AND THIS IS REAL, THIS IS
HAPPENING, NO ONE IS STOPPING
IT.
AND STEVEN MILLER IS A SENIOR
ADVISOR AND WAS FOR FOUR YEARS,
AND PLUMMETING MANY POLICIES
THAT THE BITING PEOPLE CANCELED.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
IT IS A LITTLE BIT CRAZY WHEN
YOU SEE THE NUMBERS, HOW COULD
TOM TILLIS AND OTHERS SUPPORT
GIVING AMNESTY IN THE FACE OF
THAT.
>> BECAUSE THEY SUPPORT
UNLIMITED IMMIGRATION INTO THIS
COUNTRY AND THEY BELIEVE THAT
AMERICANS CANNOT CUT IT AND THE
VALUES ARE USELESS HERE, LIKE
THE DIRT THAT YOU HAVE ON THE
GROUND, OF COURSE YOU NEED TO
BRING NEW PEOPLE.
I WOULD SAY THIS ON THE
DREAMER'S POINT SPECIFICALLY,
IT'S THE MOST INSIDIOUS FORM
THAT THEY COULD CONSIDER AND
THAT INCLUDES THOSE OF BIBLICAL
PROPORTIONS.
AND THAT INCLUDES REPATRIATION
FOR MINORS.
THAT INCLUDES THIS SENSE
PRE-AMNESTY TIMES.
YOU TALK ABOUT IT IN YOUR
OPENINGS.
SO BEFORE THAT THEY HAVE NEVER
SEEN NUMBERS, BEFORE THIS WHOLE
THING STARTED AND THEN JOE BIDEN
CAME IN AND DESPITE WARNINGS
FROM BORDER PATROL, HE SAID THAT
MINORS ARE EXEMPT FROM TITLE 42,
WE HAVE NOW SEEN ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE MONTH, EVERY SINGLE MONTH
UNDER JOE BIDEN AND THE NUMBER
OF MINORS THAT HAVE ENTERED THE
COUNTRY IS HIGHER THAN EVERY
SINGLE MONTH IN AMERICAN HISTORY
BEFORE JOE BIDEN.
AND THAT INCLUDES OTHERS THAT
ARE SAYING LET US CODIFY THE
IDEA ARE AMERICANS FOR LIFE.
IT IS INSANE TALK.
>> IT IS ENCOURAGING HUM